venons en au dossier de cette édition
consacrée à la collecte des ordures dans
la région d'un polythène depuis
plusieurs décennies
elle est en partie cette collecte géré
par la mafia locale des millions de
tonnes de déchets industriels sont tout
simplement brûlés à l'air libre ou
laissés à l'abandon au mépris de
l'écosystème et de la santé publique
marc d'haene à charles garnier c'est
apparemment un chemin de campagne comme
un autre et pourtant ces terres
agricoles qui entourent naples sont
régulièrement cultivés à l'ombre d'une
épaisse fumée noire
celle de déchets industriels brûler la à
l'air libre les gens mourront voit un
faux quelque part une fois ces six là
une fois la cgem rue même endroit des
fumées qui libère des substances
toxiques dans l'atmosphère mais la
contamination touche aussi les sols ou
produits chimiques ou métalliques sont
enfouis ici le pâturage n'est plus le
même c'est ce que nous explique la
famille canada cholo qui élève des
brebis depuis cinq générations touchées
par les cancers à répétition leur
troupeau a été décimée en quatre ans il
est passé de 2500 à 220 tête
pour antonio c'est l'herbe de vie
toxiques qui les a rendus malades
regardez ici c'est la dioxine qui a taxé
zoo les taux de dioxine de leur lait et
en douze fois supérieur à la limite
autorisée
ces bêtes vivent leurs dernières heures
laisse viande depuis toujours cette
fallu se nourrit de serait troupeau en
avril dernier le père d'antonio en est
mort à 59 ans aujourd'hui la famille
s'inquiète seule la santé des animaux
semblent préoccuper les autorités combat
comment se fait-il qu'en quatre années
il est fait quatre examens sur le relais
et aucun sur nous des services alternat
politiques sont corrompus par la camorra
la camorra la mafia napolitaine
c'est donc elle qui est à l'origine de
cette catastrophe environnementale et
sanitaire depuis trente ans de nombreux
industriels italiens
étrange et confus leurs déchets à des
sociétés contrôlées par la camorra leurs
tarifs sont imbattables et pour cause
ces déchets toxiques ne sont pas
traitées mais juste des versets avant
d'être brûlée en pleine nuit au grand
mépris de la santé publique aujourd'hui
une enquête menée par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé révèle des chiffres
inquiétants mais la médée cemaf h dans
cette même zone où l'on a recensé plus
de 1000 sites déchets toxiques
il ya une hausse importante du nombre de
cancers 9% pour les hommes 12 % pour les
femmes mais surtout une augmentation du
nombre de malformations néonatales 2 84%
à chara et dans les villages voisins aux
moeurs donc plus qu'ailleurs la petite
zone de culture maraîchère a été
rebaptisé aujourd'hui triangle de la
mort
deux cent cinquante mille personnes sont
exposées à ces substances toxiques elles
le savent mais continue de manger les
produits de leurs terres empoisonné
j'aimerais bien ne pas manger ses
produits mais il faut se nourrir que
faut-il faire
à l'image des feux visible de tous et
rarement et un les habitants déplore
l'inertie d'une administration qu'il
considère comme corrompu la camorra et
puissante elle protège un marché très
juteux
c'est ce que nous explique le juge
antimafia que nous avons rencontrée et
elle se déplace jamais sans ses trois
gardes du corps
mon papa deuxième de nombreux repenti de
la mafia de la camorra nous ont dit que
ces déchets valent de l'or parce qu'on y
fait moins attention il y a moins de
risques qu avec les trafics de drogue et
les gains sont très importants un marché
de plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'euros par an aussi rentable que celui
de la cocaïne
au total 26 millions de tonnes de
déchets auraient disparu dans la nature
l'équivalent d'une montagne de 14
kilomètres de haut de produits toxiques